[Music]
I am most of all happy and grateful to
finally be mighty as hospital we met at
a time where I was feeling very lost but
every day that since I met Marcia has
been the best days of my life
Montes taught me to always go for what
you want without any hesitation and that
has opened my life to so many new
experiences that I never would even
dream to be possible but most
importantly monster brings out the best
in me and I feel so fortunate to be
spending the rest of my life with this
amazing one
[Music]
[Applause]
what we did not know that morning when
you left was that he had gone to Italy
to meet the love of his life
mafia Marcia from the first time we met
- we realized that you and Felix are
absolutely so
[Music]
got a real good
[Applause]
[Music]
got a real good feeling right now right
now right now right now
right now
something right